en este vídeo vamos a pensar en el
mercado de manzanas pero lo más
importante no serán las manzanas lo más
importante es apreciar que en realidad
la curva de demanda de un mercado es
igual a la suma de las curvas de demanda
individuales de cada participante del
mercado en la mayoría de los mercados
tienen decenas cientos miles millones o
miles de millones de participantes en
ellos sin embargo para simplificar las
cosas vamos a suponer que el mercado de
las manzanas sólo tiene dos consumidores
pero podemos ver sus curvas de demanda
justo aquí
esta es la curva de demanda del
consumidor 1 y esta es la curva de
demanda del consumidor 2 en el eje
vertical tenemos el precio puede ser el
precio por kilogramos de las manzanas y
en el eje horizontal tenemos la cantidad
en este caso cantidad demandada y en
este ejemplo es la cantidad de
kilogramos por algún periodo de tiempo
tal vez kilogramos por semana
entonces podemos ver que para la curva
de demanda del consumidor 1 si el precio
es de 12 345 pesos entonces él no quiere
comprar ningún kilogramo con el precio
de 3 pesos por kilogramo él compra un
kilogramo por semana y con el precio de
un peso por kilogramo él compra 2
kilogramos por semana de manera similar
para el consumidor 2
algunas veces puedes ver esto mismo en
forma de tabla que comúnmente se le
conoce como una tabla de demanda podemos
ver que si tenemos un precio de 12
45 ó 67 pesos siete pesos por kilogramo
el consumidor 2 no está interesado en
manzanas mientras que a cinco pesos por
kilogramo él está interesado en comprar
dos kilogramos por semana ya tres pesos
por kilogramo el consumidor está
interesado en comprar veamos
1 2 3 4 5 kilogramos por semana y por
último a un peso por kilogramo el
consumidor 2 está interesado en comprar
78 kilogramos por semana ahora bien con
base en esta información el consumidor 1
y el consumidor 2 son los únicos
individuos en este mercado una vez más
esta es una enorme simplificación
entonces cómo se ve la curva de demanda
del mercado pausa en vídeo y piensa lo
bueno si vemos los distintos precios
digamos en un precio de 7 pesos no hay
ningún interés en las manzanas así que
pondré un punto aquí en un precio de 7
pesos
qué pasa si el precio disminuye podemos
probar en un precio de 5 pesos el
consumidor 1 sigue sin estar interesado
pero ahora el consumidor 2 está
dispuesto a comprar dos kilogramos de
manzana por semana entonces en un precio
de 5 pesos el mercado visto como un todo
está dispuesto a comprar 2 kilogramos
para el consumidor 20 kilogramos para el
consumidor 1 entonces tenemos un total
de 2 kilogramos justo aquí en el precio
de 5 pesos por kilogramo el mercado
tiene una cantidad demandada de 2
kilogramos por semana ahora vayamos a 3
pesos en un precio de 3 pesos el
consumidor 1 está dispuesto a comprar un
kilogramo por semana y el consumidor 2
está dispuesto a comprar 5 kilogramos
por semana así que en total hay una
demanda de 6 kilogramos o una cantidad
demandada de 6 kilogramos
entonces en tres pesos por kilogramo la
demanda es de 6 kilogramos por semana
así que tenemos este
de aquí y por último pero no por eso
menos importante una vez más estoy
tomando estos puntos como muestras para
explicarte que en realidad lo que
estamos haciendo es sumar es decir
estamos tomando la suma de estas dos
curvas pero de alguna forma los estamos
apilando todos estamos apilando de una
forma horizontal a diferencia de una
forma vertical porque para un precio
determinado estamos sumando las
cantidades demandadas de los
consumidores
por último vayamos al precio de un peso
en el precio de un peso por kilogramo el
consumidor uno está dispuesto a comprar
dos kilogramos por semana y el
consumidor dos está dispuesto a comprar
ocho kilogramos si los ponemos puntos 2
+ 8 nos dan 10 kilogramos por semana así
que tenemos 1
3 4 5 6 sigamos 7 8 está justo aquí y 9
y quedamos fuera de la pantalla así que
déjame moverla para que todo quede en
orden 10 perfecto entonces cuando el
precio es de un peso se está dispuesto a
comprar 10 kilogramos por semana de
hecho puedes sumar en cualquier otro
punto o cualquier otro punto en medio de
estos y lo que vamos a obtener es la
curva de demanda del mercado que se va a
ver más o menos así y puedes ver de
manera visual qué está pasando aquí para
cada determinado precio estamos sumando
las cantidades de todos los consumidores
del mercado aquí lo estamos haciendo
solo para los consumidores pero en el
mundo real
trabajamos con millones de consumidores
esto nos ayuda a entender de dónde
proviene el mercado o la curva de
demanda del mercado muy bien nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo
hasta la próxima